welcome to a fresh look at starcraft
tues co-op missions a new addition to
starcraft with legacy of the void this
mode has received resounding positive
feedback establishing it as a core part
of the starcraft experience since its
debut last November we've made
significant improvements to the mode so
let's take a look if you've ever wanted
to share the experience of playing a
starcraft campaign-style mission
alongside an ally then co-op missions is
for you queue up solo or partner with a
friend to play as one of starcraft
legendary commanders each backed by a
unique and powerful army together you
will work to defeat mission objectives
designed to stretch the boundaries of
cooperative play with each success comes
increasing reward allowing you to level
up your commanders and unlock powerful
new upgrades and of course co-op
missions comes with its own set of
achievements and account rewards that
you won't want to pass up once you've
got the basics down players can add even
more risk reward into the mix by taking
on our weekly mutation challenges
mutators our unique conditions that add
to the complexity of any co-op mission
for example you could be assaulted by an
invisible army successfully complete a
mutation challenge and you will receive
a bounty of bonus experience based on
the difficulty level you tackled
challenges will rotate on a weekly basis
and will have dozens to try your skill
lastly for the driven players out there
mastery levels open up deeper
opportunities to progress while playing
on commanders that have reached the
level cap all experience you earn on a
maxed out commander will go towards
gaining up to 90 mastery levels which
can be spent to strengthen units and
abilities across all capped commanders
co-op missions is a fantastic way to
play and share in the experience of
starcraft 2 with a friend whether
seasoned veteran or absolute beginner a
rich progression system and a diversity
of game options allow you to play at a
pace you enjoy customizing the
battleground to suit your mood and
interests thanks for watching and we'll
see you on the battlefield